it looks like a shitty building but on
the inside it feels like a fire lit
castle everybody inside all right yeah
Trey the guy who Shelby's roommates
dating he plays one of the Wizards and I
don't know anything for you but they do
magic Heidi
sure that is weird I do not have my ID
well then step aside man sorry I got
other people lining up with her
my friends are inside already all right
I probably haven't here hang on hang on
the DMV gave me this temporary license
here's a receipt to a rental car I got
an Oxnard you need to be 25 to get one
of those just see you in there okay I'll
see you inside okay I can call my mom
I'm gonna call my mom an Aquarius I was
the year the dragon I got $3 on hang on
$3 $3 3 Washington mom how old am i yeah
it's a Tuesday
it doesn't this isn't about whether it's
a Tuesday or not Trey Trey is one of the
wizards
I swear to god I know him yeah there's a
lot of wizard Google this name and see
if me comes up Facebook will prove it
for me I don't hate you but I hate
everything you stand for and everything
you're saying right now paralyze
yourself friend replace yourself it's a
legal document well you think I just
know this information you know get just
made this information out look man I'm
sorry I'm sorry for any trouble I caused
I know you're just doing a job and I'm
wondering maybe I need ID
hey hey you kind of look like me here
just pass your ID back just oh yeah no
that could wholly be me just pass it
back Brittany hey what was your favorite
Nickelodeon show in the 90s because I
can name like 17 of them because I was a
child during the 90s you want me to tell
you about TRL I remember how the world
felt after 9/11 oh my god do you realize
the people who were born in 1995
creating this park do you think they
remember 9/11 do you think they remember
can I touch you right now and not touch
all right I'm gonna go I'm gonna come
back okay this building just doesn't
have any windows that was gone up
Oh fine all right look it's last call
you go into the last half hour next time
bring it right to you oh my god yes they
are so much don't think we won't regret
this
we're gonna fiddle sticks no we're going
cuz the over tournament is gonna meet us
there and then I grind it on you like
brink your brink guy your soul skater I
can see in your eyes